[Music]
one of the most popular character
archetypes floating around it seems that
in every anime involving fights there's
always one guy who erupts at the
slightest provocation never backs down
and generally drags the whole team into
the mess he's recklessly made however
people can't help but root for this guy
mainly due to how cool strong or
otherwise badass they really are you
know the type of character I'm talking
about don't you so here's what we're
gonna do today in this video I'll be
taking some of the most hot-headed and
badass characters putting them together
and letting you decide how they hold up
against each other with a plethora of
characters to go through let's get on
with it
[Music]
starting off is chuyia from boom go
stray dogs the pork mafia executive
perfectly fits the mold of the fiery
redhead character donate the short
stature fool you two years as hot-headed
as characters come exemplified by his
tendencies to quickly pick a fight and
as a port mafia executive what's to fear
after all he wields the amazing ability
to control gravity left alone the
results show completely destructive
potential even potentially threatening
his own life should he lose control of
the final form it even puts him in a
Berserker state to boot and all of a
sudden explaining what Julia belongs to
this list suddenly becomes a lot easier
remember samurai Champloo if you do
you'll probably know who our second
candidate is yes sir I'm talking about a
hot-headed swordsman Mugen one of the
three main characters mugen's a violent
and incredibly brash rogue who's always
out for a fight a blood knight who never
knows how to say no he's one of the most
combustible elements on the show with a
personality like that you have to have
the skills to back it up so you don't
get your ass handed to you good thing
that Mugen has no shortage of fighting
skills and hearts needless to say he
makes a case with the most badass
character in his own show even more so
than the other characters who are on par
with him in terms of strength where else
do you see an Opie swordsman fight while
dancing like he does
rike are gays a shoo-in on this list if
someone's battle tactics boiled down to
attacking straight up with lots of hits
and wrestling moves that character
certainly counts as a badass hothead to
me he's prone to making grand entrances
and attack enemies on site as Sasuke
learned the hard way getting to his
position and holding on to it ain't easy
and it takes a complete badass to do so
in the tough world of the hidden cloud
village until Naruto took the title away
from him Reich our gaze widely
considered the fastest shinobi alive
fittingly done in tandem with his
lightning powers his showing against
Sasuke and Akatsuki also mark him as one
of the toughest sob s in Naruto he's a
perfect brother for someone like Killer
Bee
the guy in the main party with all the
brawn and no brains isn't exactly
expected to be the brightest guy in the
room is he for what he can't even say
Tangier owes named properly famously
mangling it numerous times the most
hilarious one being the impassioned
kentarou he belted during the ruie arc
for what intelligence he lacks you know
scheme makes up for it with heart
passion and how badass he is the
colorful and creative fighter in escape
dazzles his opponents with his
relentless attacks and determined
passion in battle he may seem to be the
one who fool goes strategy in favor of
charging head-on but you sure as hell
better be prepared to catch his head on
charge or he'll just plow straight
through you in an instant while yelling
Pig assaults there's really something
about these Spitfires that attract a
sizable part of the fan base to them
perhaps it's their strong personality or
perhaps it's the way they react the
results in some comedy intentional or
not my hero academia x-bar' coogo has no
shortage of both the spiky hair
explosive powers and loud mouths present
all you need to know about baku go
honest driven and dangerously
competitive he embodies the word
hot-headed as far as my hero academia
characters are concerned and with that
hotheadedness is a badass that refuses
to take no for an answer
when else do you regularly see a
hot-headed side character or a rival
regularly beat the hell out the
protagonist my hero academia is always
portrayed by kugo as someone who's above
deku and that's something that makes
this exploder one hell of a badass
appearances don't lie and one look at
Shizuo would chip you off that this is a
man you don't want to piss off
incredibly impulsive and hot-headed
she's was exactly the kind of person who
has the tendency to explode in a snap
hot-headed personality aside Shizuo also
brings an air of sincerity and bluntness
to complement his otherwise basic
personality
his attitude quickly puts him at odds
with his rival the sly and cerebral
Isaiah and the two quickly hit the
ground running in their hatred for each
other their battles are tales of legend
all across a Kiva poro it's a perfect
match between clever manipulation and
earnest power few powers say badass as
much as super strength and Shizuo has
that in droves in terms of physical
prowess and no one in the durarara
Universe can even come close to this
badass blonde
[Music]
the ruthless vice commander of the
shinsengumi's gained all sorts of
notoriety known for a ruthless attitude
he's Ginn Thomas epitome of a
no-nonsense character before his meeting
with Kondo he was known as someone who
often gets into fights leaving trails of
blood behind let's say that he hasn't
completely shared of his past
personality even in the present and
that's a good thing because it's also
the source of the fire that keeps him
going in battle but say that [ __ ]
garthe's will and determination to keep
going in battle is amazing even injuries
are unable to put this guy down and
that's without getting into his
swordsmanship which is among the best in
the Shinsengumi and second only to Okita
making him a fitting rival of Ginn Toki
[Music]
pizzicato is not the only one who's had
a number of malaise with the protagonist
introducing kampachi for our number
three entry captain of the battle hungry
squad 11 in Bleach
Kenpachi lives for battle a blood Knight
that thirst for combat he spends most of
his fights relishing the pain and the
bloodshed he both inflicts and receives
for Kenpachi violence is always the
answer if it doesn't solve the problem
is simply not using enough this provides
a nice contrast to the likewise
hot-headed but more empathetic
protagonist in Ichigo despite not being
the best of friends
Ichigo always knows he can count on the
squad 11 captain in times of need and
vice versa
Kenpachi remains one of the toughest
beasts in Bleach and what if I told you
that for how strong he already is
Kenpachi intentionally handicaps himself
for most of his fights highly
competitive and an extremely driven
go-getter Vegeta easily qualifies as a
hot-headed character the famous it's
over 9000 scene says it all with Vegeta
crushing his Scouter in sheer intensity
even in battle these as intense as DBZ
characters go easily trumping his rival
Goku in terms of being a combustible
element needless to say Vegeta is one
hell of a badass character yeah he jabs
a fair amount of time but those losses
are mostly to the credit of even his
tougher opponents instead of him being a
poor fighter I mean in a vacuum
Vegeta is truly one of the best
Dragonball has to offer it'll be tough
to top Vegeta's in terms of
hotheadedness and badassness but when I
think about someone who could have
overcome Vegeta
one name comes to mind
I suggest animo horrid nemo unus worker
over
shut up
protagonist of Stardust Crusaders Jotaro
remains unmatched being the epitome of
manliness himself perpetually angry he
starts off isolating himself for fear of
his power harming anyone he's gone into
a fair share of fights himself due to
his attitude something that reflects in
the nature of his stand star platinum
even his battle cry successive yellow
our telltale sign that this guy has an
ever-burning car that's my impossible to
put out then how badass is Jotaro really
well he outright stands up to do himself
firing the now famous meme of their
confrontation the seemingly unstoppable
vampire doesn't faze him instead urging
him to keep going and allowing him to
come out on top
and if that doesn't scream badass I
don't know what does Jotaro is truly the
epitome of manliness in anime and I
doubt anyone can top this one anytime
soon skittle deals shoes shoulders
[Music]
seeing characters that you expected cool
no some that didn't make the list well
that's to be expected wherever your
thoughts are I'd love to hear it from
you so I'd love you guys to get
discussions going through the comments
section below
trust me even I know that a list of 10
characters isn't enough to put together
an amaze fest of the best in just this
archetype now imagine more common
archetypes like the childhood friend the
stoic rival or the tsundere love
interest
man anyway that's gonna do it for now I
hope to see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]